Và số nhân viên liên bán hoặc hiện nghĩ phép bắt đồ có thể sẽ không được nhận lại lương sau khi chính phủ Mỹ mật gởi trở lại.
Tên bố này được tổng thống mì đường nàn trọng đưa ra sau khi trước đó đã đe zua sẽ xác thải các nhân viên liên bán trong thời gian chính phủ đồng cơ.
Phát biểu tại nhà trang án mục bởi tháng mời trong buổi tiếp thủ tưởng các nha đà ở mắt cảni, không trăm cho biết,
khu định này sẽ còn tuy thu hại vào tương trường hạc của thế.
Ông khẳng định và lớn các nhân viên sẽ được chính phủ đảm bảo quyền lời,
đuyền gó mất số người thực sự không sinh đáng và chính phủ sẽ có các dạy uất khác đồ về họ.
Tổng thống Mỹ không không cấp thêm thông tin trị đét về việc những diễn lên bằng nào có thể sẽ không đừng nên lại lương.
Theo bảo gáo của văn phòng nên xa của Mỹ và tổn chất,
ước tình có khoảng bởi trình nằm mình nghĩ những diễn bán sẽ phải nghi phép bắt bộ trong đường tổng thở chính phủ đảnh này.
Trong đó các nhân viên bán góc bộ phạt được có là tiết yêu,
trần hạn như kẹp rất viên không liệu và các quan trực thực thi tháng lần sẽ tục làm việc không liên cho đến khi chính phủ một người trở lại.